bonjour à tous aujourd'hui avec les side
société green créative qui lie à un
produit très intéressant pour pouvoir
faire le recyclage
alors est ce que tu peux l'expliquer
nous présentez vous expliquez moi ça pas
comment ça marche
c'est que là
un goûter
bouton mauvais en corse analyse ensuite
ça le combat qu'on divise par deux
on va dire
manger grâce à la connectivité du point
les plats et le 6 avr
cette annonce est en fête
est ce que c'est
à la fin
d'accord donc ça c'est un produit qui
est destiné aux entreprises
en effet les caddies sculpteur
boissons des
et qui vous longerez etc il faut des
lieux assez
les garçons boulet et 381 points
d'accord ok vous est ce qui manque c'est
un peu enfin est-ce qu est-ce qu on peut
imaginer aussi à un produit similaire
pour
pour le particulier on le dit gilles
similaires non mais pas compte des
nouvelles connectés
il ya d'autres astuces oui parce que au
final la
un écuyer milliards
syndics n'ont pas pu s'appeler
la ferme est d'accord alors tu veux
expliquer comment ça marche
techniquement on pose son gobelet sa
canette son déchet on sait que ce qui se
passe techniques ont ensuite on a une
analyse avec le croit d'accord on a
capté 7
à partir compression on a eu des rallyes
sur le bris sur la confession et
on dit pas est ce que ce sera un défi de
parts qui viennent d
papier
ok alors comment est-ce que bien qu avec
le poids on peut être sûr qu
effectivement c'est la bonne
canet offrant une canette de hal et une
canette de coca vide enfin la pub pour
coca
peu importe
comment est-ce qu'on va être sûr qu
effectivement c'est la bonne can est
est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir un poids
similaire
c'est très rare et du coup en fait on ne
plus faire
avoir une première année
il pourra maintenant du sida c'est
intéressant d'accord et après en fait le
second dit
compact on va être à nous permettre de
savoir toute la vérification des
produits et c'est là
vraiment très précis par exemple sénile
cannelle unis
bouteilles en irak dans des gobelets
puisque envers les gobelets c'est moi
que les casiers
ok ça marche donc ensuite pour les dans
le bac ses prix c'est jeter directement
par le
consommateurs enfin par la personne qui
a en charge de ça alors à qui s'adresse
du coup tu me lis plutôt aux entreprises
qui vont effectivement avoir des
distributeurs tu me dis aux boulangeries
et tout ce réseau là en fait ça va être
payant il ya des gâteaux suez mais
maître des lieux
l'entreprise par exemple des lieux
consommation donc des aéro
service des musées dédiés
avec tous les deux
y a vraiment fait énormément
wilson
ce qu'ils sont
bien
c'est vrai que ça vient d'où l'idée de
créer un produit comme celui-là c'est ce
qu'a effectivement aujourd'hui on n'est
pas en capacité de recycler correctement
ça vient ça vient de là il y avait peut
être besoin
on avait pas mal de directeur
bottes qu'il disait
rien de bien faire
penché au tri des poubelles dans les
et puis un peu là c'est parce que c'est
vrai des nouvelles de première chambre
en charge un budget il
je peux planchot
compte
on serait bien trier ses déchets la
veille au lieu de pension économique
finalement
entre noirs
erytech convaincre et des monnaies et
que c'est un produit qui est déjà sur le
marché aujourd'hui eh bien nous lançons
ici c'est le nom
machine en france sur 10
fait il ya un an
qu'ils sont beaux
rythme
annoncé également
je souhaite beaucoup de réussite en tout
cas très intéressant super conseil très
bonne idée
belle machine merci beaucoup je vous
invite bien évidemment amener des
commentaires on dire ce que vous pensez
est ce que vous pensez qu effectivement
le tri aujourd'hui ce quelque chose qui
est bien fait oui non est ce que vous
voyez vraiment l'utilité d'avoir des
machines comme celles là ont vraiment
trier correctement mais dites moi tout
ça en commentaire vous invite bien sûr
comme d'habitude à me laisser les jolies
pousse à vous abonner
on reste connectés parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus d'entreprises françaises
innovantes
merci et à bientôt ciao